Good morning, church.
Good morning. It's great to see you.
If you're new to our church, we are glad you're here.
We'd love to welcome you a little more directly if you'd let
us, if you've been here for ages, for decades,
uh, we love you as well.
We're glad you're here. Uh, by the way,
if you are a member here, please remember to, uh, vote
for the deacon candidates this year.
We've got that over, uh, the next hour.
Got time for that online or at the info desk in the lobby.
Now we have journeyed for many months through First Samuel
and then the last few months through Second Samuel.
And we've been tracing God's provision
of a king for his people.
And, and not only seeing that how
that has shown up in Israel's history,
but also how that points us to the true king.
Uh, that's the main point of these passages
yet we've also seen along with that, is the mess
that sin can create.
It has been really hard to watch King David's sin
and then the family fallout, the national fallout
that we've seen in Israel as we've walked through.
Second Samuel, especially, it's been
seemingly train wreck after train wreck.
Painful to watch. Well, today,
before we get to the end of the series, next week,
by the way, if you're dressing up, that's next week.
But as we get to that,
today feels like a breath of fresh air.
There's a le a measure of like freedom.
Today we see this
because as you turn to Second Samuel chapter 22, today,
what we find is essentially one of David's psalms.
It's a song, uh, that David wrote.
Now, by the way, if we're not gonna cover this at the end
of chapter 23, there's a record of David's mighty men,
like his 30 or so really elite warriors.
And so if you're into military and battles
and those kind of things, go read that later this afternoon.
It is awesome, like just story
after story of fighting lions and stuff.
It's pretty cool. But that's, that's what that is.
But chapter 22,
and even into chapter 23,
it's really just David praising the Lord for who God is, for
what he's done, for what he believes da God
will do in the future.
And it's just a beautiful picture
of praise in response to God.
In fact, it's repeated in Psalm 18, nearly word for word.
It's what David wrote as a song when God delivered him,
and it became a national hymn in Psalm 18 later.
And so it's a song David wrote when God delivered Him.
But it's also, I believe a song that each one of us needs
to hear and can identify with and relate to.
And we can praise God with David as we read it
because here's the reality.
Some of you are in the middle of a storm right now
and you're facing this need for deliverance or,
or maybe you're heading into a storm
and you can see it coming on the horizon
or you're out of a storm
and you're looking back reflecting on what God did through
that God's word today will give us language
with which we can praise God in the middle of
a storm that we face.
So here's what I wanna do. I wanna read the whole thing.
That means 51 verses chapter 22 is 51 verses long and
and I just, I wanna do that
because this is a song
just like we don't really break up songs, we verse chorus,
that kind of stuff, but we don't stop after the verse.
We do the whole thing, let it speak.
And so that's what this is.
Let God's word speak as it was intended.
So read the whole thing, then come back
and we'll give three quick truths to hang on
to about God in response, but,
but we're just gonna read the whole thing.
And so what I hope as we kind of kind of gear up for,
it's gonna take a couple minutes, but what I hope we can do
as you're listening or reading it in front of you,
just worship with this
like just let this spark your heart to worship.
Second Samuel 22,
and David spoke to the Lord the words
of this song on the day when the Lord delivered him from the
hand of all his enemies from the hand of Saul,
and he said, the Lord is my rock and my fortress
and my deliverer, my God, my rock in whom I take refuge,
my shield and the horn of my salvation, my stronghold,
my refuge, my savior, you save me from violence.
I call upon the Lord who is worthy to be praised
and I'm saved from my enemies.
For the waves of death encompassed me.
The torrance of destruction assailed me.
The cords of sheel entangled me.
The snares of death confronted me in my distress.
I called upon the Lord to my God.
I called and from his temple, he heard my voice
and my cry came to his ears.
Then the earth reeled
and rocked the foundations of the heavens, trembled
and quaked because he was angry.
Smoke went up from his nostrils,
devouring fire from his mouth, glowing coals,
flamed forth from him.
He bowed the heavens and came down.
Thick darkness was under his feet.
He rode on a cherub and flew.
He was seen on the wings of the wind.
He made darkness around him, his canopy, thick clouds,
a gathering of water outta the brightness
before him, coals of fire flamed forth.
The Lord thundered from heaven
and the most high uttered his voice and he sent out arrows
and scattered them lightning and routed them.
Then the channels of the sea were seeing the foundations
of the world were laid bare at the rebuke of the Lord.
At the blast of the breath of his nostrils,
he sent from on high.
He took me. He drew me out of many waters.
He rescued me from my strong enemy, from those who hated me,
for they were too mighty for me.
They confronted me in the day of my calamity,
but the Lord was my support.
He brought me out into a broad place.
He rescued me because he delighted in me.
The Lord dealt with me according to my righteousness,
according to the cleanness of my hands, he rewarded me
for I've kept the ways of the Lord,
have not wickedly departed from my God
for all his rules were before me
and from his statutes I did not turn aside.
I was blameless before him and I kept myself from guilt
and the Lord has rewarded me according to my righteousness,
according to my cleanness, in his sight.
With the merciful, you show yourself merciful.
With the blameless man.
You show yourself blameless with the purified.
You deal purely and with the crooked.
You make yourself seem torturous.
You save a humble people,
but your eyes are on the haughty, the prideful
to bring them down for you are my lamp, oh Lord.
And my God lightens my darkness for by you.
I can run against a troop
and by my God, I can leap over a wall.
This God, his way is perfect.
The word of the Lord proves true.
He is a shield for all those who take refuge in him for
who is God but the Lord and who is a rock except our God.
This God is my strong refuge and has made my way blameless.
He made my feet like the feet of a deer
and set me secure on the heights.
He trains my hands for war so
that my arms can bend a bow of bronze.
You've given me the shield of your salvation
and your gentleness made me great.
You gave a wide place for my steps under me
and my feet did not slip.
I pursued my enemies and destroyed them
and did not turn back until they were consumed.
I consumed them. I thrust them through so they did not rise.
They fell under my feet for you equipped me with strength
for the battle you made.
Those who rise against me sink under me.
You made my enemies turn their backs to me, those
who hated me and I destroyed them.
They looked, but there was none to save.
They cried to the Lord, but he did not answer them.
I beat them fine as the dust of the earth.
I crushed them, stamped them down like
the mire of the streets.
You delivered me from strife with my people.
You kept me as the head
of the nations people whom I had not known served me.
Foreigners came cringing to me.
As soon as they heard of me, they obeyed me.
Foreigners lost heart came trembling outta their fortresses.
The Lord lives and blessed be my rock
and exalted be my God, the rock of my salvation.
The God who gave me vengeance
and brought down peoples under me,
who brought me out from my enemies.
You exalted me above those who rose against me.
You delivered me from men of violence for this.
I will praise you, oh Lord, among the nations
and sing praises to your name.
Great salvation he brings to his king
and shows steadfast love to his anointed, to David
and his offspring forever.
Isn't that amazing?
Like just amazing truths.
In fact, here's what I want us to do with, with
that in your mind now, like you've just heard that
and maybe it's sitting in front of you on your Bible
or open on your device, like let's just respond just like
David in, in, out loud praise
to the Lord all at the same time.
We've done this a few times over the years, right?
Like everybody praying out loud in response in
praise to God.
Now don't worry, God's a big God. He can sort it out.
You're talking, but they're talking too. That's okay.
You can all talk at the same time. God can understand it.
Just give him praise, right?
Let's let this be the words to who God is.
Tell him who he is. Remind him of that.
Be praising God all out loud.
Let this prompt your words
and let's just practice praising God together.
Okay? Let's go everybody out loud together. Just praise him.
Lord, thank you for who you are,
that your word gives us words, gives us language
with which to praise you, that we can use the very words
of David, your words through David to
praise you just like He did to remind you of who you are.
You didn't forget, but we forget.
So Lord, may we live with that kind
of praise on our lips every day for your glory,
for our good, but mostly for your glory
in Jesus' name.
Amen. That's pretty cool, right?
You've maybe never prayed out loud before.
Well, now you have. And so just keep going, keep going,
pray out loud where you are with others as well.
Now we're gonna come back and actually sing some
of those words from two Samuel 22 later.
But I did say three truths you can hang on to.
Here's the first one. God delivers his people
first truth, God delivers his people.
The context of this song, remember is
that it's pointing to God's deliverance.
Saul was chasing after David and even after Saul died.
It was his family, it was household,
it was other allies of Saul.
They were still coming after David.
And so David wasn't even free after Saul died.
There were other enemy armies around Philistines, others
pressing in on Israel.
And so David's in this place of needing deliverance,
but the Lord delivered David.
All of this, the whole thing points to God's deliverance
of David in very real ways.
Victory given through all kinds of different means.
That's why you saw David say things like verse two,
the Lord is my rock and my fortress and my deliverer.
Verse three, my God, my rock in whom I take refuge.
That's you need something protection.
He's the one verse three, my savior,
you save me from violence.
Verse four, he said, I call upon the Lord who is worthy
to be praised and I am saved from my
enemies deliverance.
You even saw the power
of God coming through on behalf of David.
Like verse 10, he bowed the heavens and came down.
What did he come down as? He came down as God,
the deliverer for David.
There's language of rescue all throughout the passage.
Verse 31, he's a shield.
It means you hide behind him for those
who take refuge in him.
Verse 44, you delivered me from strife with my people.
Verse 49, he says, God brought him out, brought him outta
what brought him outta the mess that he was in
and the enemies that were surrounding him brought him out
to a safe place.
The whole chapter filled with deliverance language,
which is why David ended with this.
Remember verse 50, he said this
for this, what's this?
The deliverance for this.
I will praise you, oh Lord, among the nations
and sing praises to your name.
Deliverance led to praise.
Salvation led to worship.
But let's not forget this was not just any old run
of the mill deliverance.
Like it wasn't like David got an F on a grade on a test one
time and somehow still passed the class
because his professor was full of grace, right?
Like, man, God delivered me. Yeah, okay. Somewhat.
But Remember like this was deliverance
and David was in desperate need of deliverance.
Like this was through desperation.
I guess if you got an F on a final,
you might feel desperate, but this is like real desperation,
the desperate storms he was facing.
'cause remember this, David was facing
seemingly insurmountable armies coming at him.
The king was trying to exterminate him.
He was facing rebellion from within his own family
who were trying to take the throne away from him.
David was facing desperation in its pure form.
That's why he says in verse five, for the waves of death
encompassed me, the Torrance of destruction assailed me.
He was feeling as if he was dying, yet he was still alive.
David also wrote Psalm 23,
and it says in there, even though I walk through the valley
of the shadow of death, that's what he's feeling right now.
The Torrance of destruction, that waves of death.
And then verse seven, in my distress,
I called upon the Lord.
To my God, I called. He's in a bad spot.
But did you notice what God did in response?
The next verse is talk about how when David cries out
Or the earth shakes the heavens trembled, it talks about
how this God, he's praying to came down.
All because one man cried out in faith, God,
I need you, God, I need you.
And he said, I'm here.
And look at the power he brought with them.
Listen, God is not some deity out there somewhere
who is unmoved by his people's distress.
He's not just out there kinda like,
well, hope it all works out.
No, he is actually the warrior king who rides in
to rescue his beloved like way better than any
of those Hallmark movies that you'll watch
here in the next month, right?
Like this rescuer comes
to save her from the the country, right?
No, it's like this is true rescue. This is true desperation.
This is true rescue where he's the warrior king.
Don't think that just
because you're going through a trial right now,
that somehow God is absent.
Now we know from Second Samuel you might be suffering
because of your sin and you might not get
outta that consequence.
But our trials are also the occasions
for God's spectacular intervention.
When you're facing something
that you don't feel like you can ever get out of,
you feel like there's no hope,
his intervention is often spectacular.
Think back the very beginning
of this entire series in one Samuel
Hannah prayed in one Samuel chapter two,
She prayed a desperate prayer because she was barren.
She could not have children, and she was desperate
and she'd been praying for years
and for years and for years.
And God finally answered that prayer with Samuel
and her prayer in response in First Samuel chapter two is
nearly identical to
what David prays right here about God being our rock,
God being our deliverer.
And God's not only gonna deliver us today,
he's gonna deliver forever.
That's her prayer. That's David's prayer.
What was the kicker in both of them? Desperation.
They were desperate. God answered.
God came through and they praised in response.
Here's the question. Do you see your desperate circumstances
as opportunities to witness God's delivering power?
Like is that how you view 'em?
You're in a crisis, you're in a tough spot
and you see this is an opportunity for God to show up.
Is that how you see it?
Or do you think this one's too big for God?
This one's too much. Like do you believe? Is that in there?
Is that, is that maybe in the back of your mind like, ah,
I don't know if God can handle this one?
Is that, is that where your heart is?
Or maybe you've just become satisfied
and comfortable in your own
self-sufficiency to handle the problem.
Crisis comes. Difficulty shows up.
I got this, I got this.
I just gotta man up and take care of it. I can handle this.
Is that where you are?
You've heard the phrase, God
helps those who help themselves.
That's not in here. Just
so you know, it's not true.
It's not that God helps those who help themselves. No.
God saves those who know they need to be saved.
God delivers those who know they need to be delivered.
God reaches in just like David in his desperation.
God reaches in and says, I'm going to save you
because you know you need me.
That's the way God designed us to
Work.
We're not meant to be self-sufficient.
We're meant to need him,
and that's the best place for us to be.
God delivers his people even through our desperation.
Here's the second truth. It's
that God rewards the
righteous God rewards.
We saw this in Second Samuel 22. God rewards the righteous.
And we not only see it here in this chapter,
we see it throughout first and second Samuel.
Various ways We see that when we follow,
when a person follows God's will,
when they obey God's plan, life works better.
Like life works better it.
It may not be perfect because
we still live in a fallen world.
We still have broken bodies. Life won't be perfect,
but life will certainly go better when we live according
to the way God designed it to live.
When you submit your plans to God
and follow his plan,
instead you are then not only following a, a better path
for life, you're also under the covering of God's blessing.
You're under the cover of His fullness
that you're receiving.
That's what David was referring to here,
chapter 22, verse 21.
He said it this way, the Lord dealt with me according
to my righteousness, according to the cleanness of my hands.
He rewarded me. He kept God's ways.
He didn't follow through with the wicked ways.
He was innocent, he was blameless.
He says in verse 25, follows with this in response,
the Lord has rewarded me according to my righteousness,
according to my cleanness in his sights.
Here's the problem with all that though.
We having walked this long month journey,
we know we're not reading this in isolation.
Are we? Like if we just read that
and David's like, man, this guy's great.
He might've written this at the beginning of his life,
earlier in life, but we know
it's included at the end of his life.
And so when we know on our side of this We know
that David was not innocent,
he was clearly not like how?
How could the murderous adulterer say all that?
How could he claim to be clean, to be innocent?
How could he claim to be blameless?
How could he claim to have followed the Lord's plan? How?
How could he? 'cause here's
what I believe he's speaking of.
He's speaking of directional faithfulness.
Was David Sinlessly perfect?
No, Clearly not.
That's why the point is not to follow David.
The point is to follow the true king Jesus
who was sinlessly perfect.
We don't trust in man. We trust in God, But
but notice the comparison made He, he talks about how
I have not wickedly departed from my God.
Think back to the whole journey we've walked through.
First and second Samuel, have we seen kings
wickedly depart from God?
Saul. Saul did.
So in a sense, there's a comparison all throughout one,
two Samuel of the way Saul lived
and the way David has lived.
'cause here's the difference. Saul was
directionally unfaithful.
He sinned, he followed the way of the world,
followed his own flesh, and he never turned back to God.
He never directionally followed the Lord,
never really wanted to.
And in fact, his focus was on maintaining his own
little K kingdom.
David also sinned,
but directionally was oriented towards the kingdom
of God being first and foremost, not his own kingdom.
He was not worried about maintaining his kingdom.
He wanted God's kingdom. And that's a major difference.
Directionally unfaithful, directionally faithful,
not perfect, but faithful to follow,
keep returning, keep repenting,
keep setting up structures not to go back to the sin.
That is what he's talking about right here.
And listen, God will reward that.
God will reward that kind of faithfulness again, even
through our imperfection.
God is a gracious God who will reward those who pursue him.
It's very clear even in this chapter that God is going
to discipline and even condemn
and punish those who are walking away from him.
But those who walk towards him, those
who are oriented towards him,
he's gonna reward, he's gonna bless.
Now I know talking about reward
and blessing makes us a little uncomfortable at times
because that has been co-opted into thinking that man,
when you follow God and you obey God,
he's gonna make you healthy.
He's gonna milk you, make you wealthy,
he's gonna give you everything you would ever want.
That's also not in here.
So it's not, his reward is going to be health, wealth,
comfort, all the good things
you could ever dream about in life.
That's not the reward he's talking about.
He might not even give you back everything you had
before you sinned.
Like that's a reality here.
We saw it all over Second Samuel,
there's consequences to sin.
It doesn't mean that when you repent,
God's gonna just make it all right
and go right back to everything the way it was before.
You might have to pay the consequence of
that sin the rest of your life.
But here's the difference, James four eight says,
draw near to God.
He will draw near to you.
That's the reward.
It's not stuff, it's not comfort. It's not a better life.
The reward is God himself. It's his presence.
It's his joy through whatever you're facing, sustaining you
through whatever you're facing, the peace
of God washing over you to walk
through whatever you're facing.
That's the reward he promises to give you.
David was more concerned about God's presence rather than
what he would get from God.
That's what it means to be a man after God's own heart.
Remember, that's David's like catchphrase.
That's what people called him. A man after God's own heart.
That's what it means.
It doesn't mean you're never sin, it just means
that your deepest desire is for God himself,
above all else, above freedom, above security, above money,
above relationships, my greatest desire,
those are good things.
My greatest desire is for God himself.
And that righteousness he talks about is a blood bot covered
by grace Covenant, keeping God kind of righteousness.
It's a righteousness that he says himself,
you have given to me.
He knows he was wrong. He knows he was sinful.
He knows he blew it in big ways,
but he said, God, you've given me your righteousness.
And listen, David only knew
that in seed form the the same righteousness he's talking
about is what we know in full today came through the life,
death and resurrection, perfect life, substitutionary death,
victorious resurrection of Jesus Christ in your place.
That's the righteousness that we now know is
what he was talking about.
And that is an imputed righteousness that's given to you.
It's not like you earned that. You can't do the same thing.
You can't even live. You've already blown it.
You can't do that. Jesus did it for you.
That's the righteousness he's talking about.
That's why listen, that's why
it's not about your past anymore.
It's about your future trajectory.
Because if that is true, the past you have,
that's nasty that you've sinned.
Every one of us has.
It's not about that anymore because it has been washed away.
It's been clean. You have to pay consequence in some form
for it in this life probably.
But it's been washed spiritually clean forever.
It's not about that anymore.
It's about your future trajectory.
And for those of us who are in Christ by faith,
that means there's hope forever.
Because we have a victorious king who beat death.
And that's hope for us. Not only forever, but even today.
He beat sin. He beat death.
We don't have to be defeated by our past, paralyzed
by our past anymore.
There's always hope.
Is that how you are pursuing the Lord today
in that kind of spirit, in that kind of power
of the grace of God?
Or are you paralyzed by your past?
You stuck by thinking that I can't get outta this.
Look at what I've done. I've already blown it.
I'm disqualified. Are you stuck by that
or are you following Jesus?
Say, Jesus the hope future, you've covered my past.
I have hope forever. And
that's the power I'm walking in now.
Is that how you're following Jesus?
Or maybe this you, you see the cost is too great.
Maybe the cost of having to deal with your past
or get rid of it or give it up or
or whatever it is that you have to deal.
And that's a big cost. I gotta give that.
I gotta stop doing that. There's a cost.
Do you see the reward offered
as infinitely better than
whatever cost you would have to pay?
Do you see it that way?
Like we talk about pick up your cross, follow Jesus.
Yes, that's true. But do you, do you see the reward?
Like is it not worth it to follow Jesus
and to say, man, you're worth it.
Jesus said it himself.
Matthew 19, everyone who has left houses or brothers
or sisters or father or mother or children or lands
or let me add to it or sin or selfishness or this thing
or that thing or whatever the world might offer
for my name's sake, he says, will receive a hundred fold
and will inherit eternal life.
What he is saying is that he rewards his people.
He's not a cosmic killjoy just trying to keep you down.
He's saying, I've got better for you.
I've got something way better than what this stuff is.
I've got something way better than you stuck in your past.
I got something way better than
that little temporary pleasure.
I got something way better. Here's the reward.
Come follow me. We're a little hedonistic
in our souls, aren't we?
Like we all want pleasure.
We all look for the the joy of the world.
We want the world stuff. We wanna feel good.
This is the highest pleasure, the highest joy, the highest
satisfaction is in Jesus alone.
He rewards his people with himself,
even through our imperfection by the grace of God.
Here's our third and final truth today.
We need to look at the last verse
of this chapter very carefully.
I want you to see verse 51 again,
great salvation he brings to his king
and shows steadfast love to his anointed, to David
and his offspring forever.
You see what David just did there?
There's a transition that he brings where he's praising God
for his salvation, all that he's done to deliver him.
But there's a subtle shift to where he looks forward
to future kings.
Again, we don't know exactly when he,
he recorded this passage, but it's included here at the end
because the very next verse, chapter 23, verse one says,
these are the final words, the last words of David.
So in some way, chapter 22,
this whole song he writes, Knights
is in preparation for,
and at the last words, kind of at the end
of his life on his deathbed,
these are the most important things he could say.
Here's what you guys need to remember
as you have kings in the future.
Look at chapter 23 verses one through five.
Now these are the last words of David, the Oracle of David,
the Son of Jesse, the oracle of the man
who was raised on high, the anointed of the God of Jacob,
the sweet psalmist of Israel.
The spirit of the Lord speaks by me.
His word is on my tongue. The God of Israel has spoken.
The rock of Israel has said to me,
when one rules justly over men ruling in the fear of God,
he dawns on them like the morning light,
like the sun shining forth on a cloudless morning like rain
that makes grass to sprout from the earth.
For does not my house stand so with God, for he has made
with me an everlasting covenant ordered in all things
and secure for will he not cause
to prosper all my help and my desire.
I especially love that last verse
where you can imagine David on his deathbed saying these
words, looking back over his life.
He's just stunned in awe that God would choose his family
to be the lineage of the eternal king,
the Messiah, the anointed one.
Like just amazed by this.
It's almost exactly
what he prayed back in the temple when God gave him the
covenant that said, you're gonna have an
eternal son on the throne.
David praised this in second Samuel seven, verse 18.
King David went in and sat before the Lord
and said, who am I?
Oh Lord God. And what is my house
that you have brought me thus far?
There was gratitude here.
There's this humility saying, God, I'm so weak.
Look at this. How could I ever meet the needs
that you have put before me?
God, who am I? Who's my family We're nothing.
So there was gratitude here that God thank you for this.
But there's also in these last words of David,
there's prophetic words here.
Verse three, this king rules justly,
righteously over men ruling in the fear of God.
David did that in part, but he didn't do that perfectly.
David himself, that's why David himself knew his throne,
but a shadow of something that was to come in the future.
He knew that his throne pointed beyond itself
to an eternal king that we know Jesus Christ to be.
And that's the main point of this whole thing.
Of course, first
and second Samuel points us to the king,
the Messiah who's coming, who's Jesus.
But don't forget what God was doing.
Also through first and second Samuel, in spite
of David's flaws, his shortcomings,
God was using David to bring about
and establish his kingdom.
God was using David to establish his kingdom
to begin the process of showing the kingdom.
That's what God was doing, right?
He was setting up a tangible expression of his presence
and his power through his people on earth.
God wanted a people. It's why he created humans.
He wanted a people to reflect his nature
and reflect his character to the world.
He wanted people to look at his children, his people,
and say, that's what God is like.
Now, clearly Israel didn't do that.
Well, we don't do that perfectly.
That's what Jesus was perfectly the true image of God.
Yet we still are called to be that same thing
as God's people individually and together.
The image of God showing the kingdom of God
to the world around us.
And just like David who was weak, God used him through that.
Today He does the same thing through our limitations.
Even through our limitations.
God establishes his kingdom on earth here.
When Jesus showed up, the kingdom of God is here.
He all over the parables. This is the kingdom of God.
This is what the kingdom of God's like.
This is what the kingdom, we should live that.
That's what he's telling us.
The kingdom of God shows up through us.
Think about David. God took a shepherd.
Boy, made him a king.
The eighth Son should never have been that
God took a shepherd, boy, made him mc king.
God took a flawed man, made him the ancestor of the Messiah.
But isn't that the stunning pattern of grace anyway?
Like doesn't deserve it. Shouldn't have it.
You got it Anyway, that's grace.
But listen, don't, God doesn't wait for perfect people.
He's just up there twiddling his thumbs,
waiting for somebody to be perfect.
He doesn't wait for perfect people.
He transforms willing people
into vessels of his eternal purpose.
So don't sit there and think your weakness is some kind
of disqualification before God.
Like you know how weak you are.
You know how limited you are. Ah, man, I'm disqualified.
No, your weakness is the very canvas on which God
paints his glory.
It's how he shows off to the world if you're willing.
And I just thought of, uh, the Apostle Paul
Who's praying for God to take away this physical ailment
that he had that made him weak.
God, take it away. God, take it away. God take it away.
And this is God's response to him.
Second Corinthians 12, nine, my grace is sufficient for you.
For my power is made perfect in weakness.
That's what God said to him.
Paul's like, Hey man, God, can you take this away from me?
And God's like, Nope. My grace is sufficient for you.
My power is actually made perfect in your weakness.
So here's what Paul said back,
therefore, I will boast all the more gladly of my weaknesses
so that the power of Christ may rest upon me.
See, when you are weak and God still moves,
it's obvious who's doing it.
My problem most of my life, I think I can do it myself.
I trust my own strength, my own resources, my own abilities.
Which by the way, God gave me all those to begin with.
So I don't know why I'm trusting myself,
but when I do that, when I preach pastor live in my own
strength, who gets the glory I do.
When We as a church use our resources
and we make some stuff happen
and we can accomplish big things?
Who gets the glory? We do.
But when we are weak and we remember that we're weak
and we come to him willing yet still weak,
and God still does something big with that.
Who gets the glory? God does.
The point of this whole thing is for God to get the glory.
And so here's the question. Will you offer
to God your imperfect
and weak life as the raw materials for his perfect purposes?
You're a mess. I'm a mess. So we, we we're weak.
We bring very little to the table here.
All he's asking you to do is just say, okay, God,
take this like five loaves, two fish kind of thing.
Take this and do something with it.
And what did he do with the five loaves of two fish?
He fed thousands upon thousands of people
with a Hebrew happy meal like this.
Are you willing to be used for God's purposes?
God used the weakness of David to prepare
for Christ's coming.
God wants to use you
to advance Christ's kingdom today.
However, I wanna invite the worst leaders out out,
'cause we're gonna sing here in a second.
I want to be C careful
because I know some of you are going
through a storm right now and it's so cloudy
and it's so dark that you can't even hear what I'm saying.
You can't even hear what God's word has shown us today.
And you're going through that storm,
or maybe you're about to head into one.
You can see it coming on the horizon.
What do you do with that? That's why it is so critical
for us to remember
and rehearse what God has done just like second Samuel 22,
to keep going back to that, to do what David did
and say, God, you delivered me here.
I remember you delivered that person.
I remember you delivered Moses,
I remember you delivered them.
And I wanna celebrate your righteousness to keep going back
to that over and over and over.
'cause the more you remember, the more likely you will do
what Hebrews 13 says,
and continually offer a sacrifice of praise to God.
That is the fruit of lips that acknowledge his name.
I said it earlier, remembrance, deliverance leads to praise
When we remember, when we look back and we think
and we reflect on His deliverance, his salvation
that leads to worship.
And so as we think about all that, God has said to us
through his word in two Samuel 2223, when we see His glory,
we see his power.
Here's my question to you right now.
How do you need him to be that for you right now?
Like, what is the, the storm you're facing,
the enemy you're facing?
What is it in your life right now that you read this
and you're like, God, I I need that from you.
I need that right now. I need you to be my rock, my refuge.
I need you to lead me on a path that keeps me from falling.
I need you to be that for me. I need your salvation.
I need your deliverance. Do that for him right now.
Just cry out to him in that state right now
with a spirit of praise, with a spirit of of submission
to his will, saying, God, I'm crying out to you.
Your will be done on earth as is in heaven.
Do it in my life first.
God, I'm crying out to you for your help.
What do you need him to be that for you right now?
Tell him. Cry out to him.
Be weak. Be needy. Tell him you need him.